aujourd'hui j'ai le plaisir de recevoir
le journaliste bertin leblanc bonjour
bonjour merci beaucoup d'avoir accepté
notre invitation
c'est je le disais c'est un plaisir de
vous recevoir vous avez travaillé ici à
france 24 au début de la chaîne n'a
d'ailleurs longtemps travaillé ensemble
vous avez aussi longtemps travaillé pour
de nombreux médias canadiens pour tv5
monde et puis vous avez changé de vie
est devenue notamment ensuite porte
parole de la secrétaire général de la
francophonie sté michaëlle jean à
l'époque vous avez été son porte parole
pendant quatre des cinq ans de son
mandat et de cette expérience vous avez
fait une bande dessinée avec le
dessinateur paul gros éléments de
langage aux éditions la boîte à bulles
avec en sous titre cacophonie en
francophonie vous y décrivent et donc
votre aventure de deux porte parole de
l'organisation internationale de la
francophonie
en gros la gestion des crises la
diplomatie l' influence politique des
pays francophones sur cette institution
d'abord pourquoi avoir signé cette bd
pourquoi avoir fait le choix de raconter
cette expérience
d'abord en fait comme j'ai pris ce poste
je vous l'avais dit je suis d'abord et
avant tout journaliste et donc je me
suis retrouvé dans cette aventure avec
avec ce regard là et très vite comme
vous l'avez dit on s'est retrouvé dans
une crise politique médiatique mais j'ai
conservé ce regard donc et aussi à la
fin de cette aventure une fois que
michaëlle jean avait perdu son poste
j'avais un sentiment assez fort
d'injustice parce qu'en fait on n'a pas
donné la chance au coureur madame jean
s'est beaucoup investi dans cette
fonction pendant quatre ans et elle a
été éjectée assez rapidement en fait
sans véritable explication donc après
quelques mois de réflexion je me suis
dit j'ai cherché le format en fait pour
essayer d'exprimer ce conte ce qu'on
avait vécu
maman et son équipe et j'ai trouvé que
la bd était probablement à des uns des
meilleurs vecteurs parce que ça permet
d'aborder des choses graves importante
mais sans trop se prendre au sérieux
avec des dessins qui donc signé paul
gros vous décrivez comme on veut gérer
les crises de l'intérieur jusqu'au de
pouvoir aux jeux politiques qui vont
donc empêcher un mickaël gens d'obtenir
un second mandat votre travail va vite
consisté à à sortir des chausse trapes
signé une affaire de l'appartement
dispensée par le canada à michaëlle jean
dans lequel vont avoir lieu des travaux
coûteux l'histoire son chauffeur aussi
utilisé de temps à autre par son mari
c'est ça le métier de porte parole dans
ce genre de situation tenter de boucher
les trous pour éviter que le bateau
prend l'eau au boulier en partie vous
attendiez à sa non pas du tout moi
j'étais j'avais pris cette fonction en
croyant que j'allais raconter l'histoire
de la francophonie ça reste une une
organisation extrêmement intéressante
c'est 88 états et gouvernements qui se
sont unis autour de la langue française
pour faire la promotion de valeurs qu'on
a en commun je vous rappelle que ce que
disait senghor s'est on a trouvé cette
langue dans les vestiges de la
décolonisation donc c'était plutôt le
projet très intéressant la politique
étant ce qu'elle est la diplomatie et
les luttes de pouvoir étant ce qu'elles
sont je me suis retrouvé effectivement
dans cette dans cette aventure avec une
crise médiatique à gérer entre autres
d'abord au canada et ensuite en france
et puis un peu plus largement dans la
francophonie faut savoir que madame jean
est d'origine canadienne on s'est
retrouvé très vite dans cette posture où
on devait défendre certain nombre
d'investissements qu'avait décidé
l'organisation et non pas madame jean
pour un appartement de fonction en fait
comme vous savez ce genre de deux postes
vient toujours avec ce qui va avec en
fait le projet que qu'avait
l'organisation à l'époque c'était de
doter l'organisation d'une résidence
officielle comme c'est un peu la
pratique de façon générale et ça a été
assez mal compris au canada on l'a
probablement aussi assez mal expliqué
mais effectivement c'est une c'est une
difficulté qu'on a souvent une fois que
la narration est parti madame j'en avais
un peu cette cette réputation d'être une
femme très investis mais qui aussi était
voilà voilà des choses en grand c'est
quelqu'un à la forte personnalité et qui
peut parfois être clivante
notamment le voit avec justin trudeau
dans cette bande dessinée où elle lui en
laisse pas place et une et salves ex
énormément vous travaillez donc avec l
nommé à l'époque par françois hollande
michaëlle jean ancienne gouverneure du
canada de conviction caractère bien
trempé elle est franche directe parfois
son désavantage et on découvre aussi si
on ne le sait pas que le bilan travail
l'engagement c'est face à la politique
pourquoi autant de
d'appétit de convoitises autour de cet
organe qui est de l'organisation
internationale de la francophonie
il faut rappeler que le waalo iev
organisée salle la francophonie est une
entité à
a2a deux bras fort en fait c'est à dire
la coopération et la dimension
diplomatique ce qui fait que cette cette
dimension a été la dimension politique a
été est convoité évidemment parce que ça
reste un poste où on peut prendre la
parole on peut dire des choses et c'est
ce qu'a fait de façon assez importante
michaëlle jean vrai franc parler avec un
vrai franc parler elle a levé cette
approche un peu noire américaine des
choses
avec un franc parler avec les chefs
d'état entre autres élèves et une visite
en centrafrique par exemple dans un
hôpital où tout est calibré mais vous
allez décider d'aller voir les femmes
violées ce qui n'était pas prévu au
programme et elle va d'ailleurs prendre
position est tout à fait parce que c'est
en fait de la mission que que mika les
gens se donnait c'était effectivement
d'être présente sur des questions
fondamentales comme celle des droits
humains celle la défense des femmes et
démocratie en général ce qui fait que je
dirais que sa posture générale sur sur
la politique à un peu dérangée
probablement l'état français qui
considérait que cette dimension
politique prenez un peu trop de place au
goût du gouvernement français et en plus
il va falloir placer quelqu'un d'autre à
sa place plutôt que de renouveler son
mandat on est en pleine tentative de
réconciliation entre la france et le
rwanda entre emmanuel macron et et paul
kagame est soucieux de cette
réconciliation bien et emmanuel macron
va plutôt choisir la la candidature
d'une rwandaise louise mushikiwabo
c'est dur à prononcer d'ailleurs vous
nous faites des des cours d'élocution à
la fin du livre problème c'est que le
rwanda il est plus francophone depuis le
génocide on a banni le français pourtant
c'est sa candidature qui va être poussée
c'est à nouveau la realpolitik qui va
primer sur le sur le travail de cette
organisation est d'ailleurs
vouliez une tribune qui est publié dans
la presse face à cette candidature
tribune qui dit notamment que la
solidarité entre francophones ne serait
qu'une simple variable d'ajustement
vous le pensez c'est le sentiment qu'on
a eu à l'époque vraiment en fait
la décision d'éliminer michaëlle jean de
ce poste a été prise bien avant ce début
de réconciliation avec le rwanda que je
salue par ailleurs c'est un travail bien
sûr voire très important à faire après
fallait-il le faire au détriment de
l'organisation malade j'en avais déjà
une feuille de route imposante quatre
ans
vous savez comme moi dans une
organisation c'est pas lui c'est un
temps être relativement court pour faire
les réformes et cetera donc on a eu
l'impression d'avoir été un peu fauchés
rapidement en plein cours de ce mandat
ensuite il y avait d'importantes
questions qu'on se posait sur
effectivement l'origine politique de
madame mushikiwabo
au coeur du projet de l'organisation
internationale de la francophonie
il ya ces valeurs fondamentales sur la
démocratie la liberté d'expression la
liberté de la presse etc peut pas dire
que le rwanda aujourd'hui est un modèle
à ce niveau donc c'est pour ça qu'on
veut on a essayé de se battre sur ces
questions là on n'a pas gagné on n'a pas
eu d'explication véritable non plus du
principal le jir et acteurs de cette
décision qui le président a répondu il
ya beaucoup de d'hypocrisie et de sa
part de justin trudeau aussi d'ailleurs
ouais la révolution et la posture pour
le canada était un peu difficile parce
qu'on on était un peu dans une
difficulté et médiatique au canada donc
ça devenait un peu compliqué pour le
gouvernement canadien nous soutenir la
démarche après je pense qu'il y avait ce
qu'on disait souvent aux autorités
canadiennes c'est mais regardez qui vous
avez en face certes vous aurez un peu de
difficulté à expliquer nos
investissements en matière de
diplomatique et immobilière à paris mais
voyez à plus long terme et je pense
qu'aujourd'hui la diplomatie canadienne
se trouve un peu en difficulté parce
qu'effectivement les quatre premières
années du mandat noualhat mushikiwabo a
entraîné un certain nombre d'affaires et
l'interrogation il ya une interrogation
très très forte au canada aujourd'hui
sur à quoi sert cette organisation vous
savez on est très sensible au canada sur
l'argent public et on voit pas très bien
encore aujourd'hui malgré les
explications qu'on a tenté à l'époque et
malgré les efforts de manas mushikiwabo
au canada récemment à quoi sert cette
organisation est ce que ça a changé
votre vision de des grandes institutions
internationales
oui forcément parce que de l'intérieur
en fait c'est ce que j'ai voulu faire
avec ce livre c'est y est de raconter
comment ça se passe réellement à
l'intérieur et effectivement dans une
organisation multi multilatéral où on a
deux nombreux
jeux direct de nombreux intervenants on
est une organisation internationale avec
des pays des cultures et des strates
grande faune hisser ses 80 huîtres et a
donc effectivement c'est cette vision
que j'avais été un peu forcément
joli naïve et khaled al été fortement
fracassée par la realpolitik parler les
jeux de coulisses que quand on décrit
dans le livre avec paul gros parce que
parce que les intérêts finalement d'un
pays dominent sur un autre essai des
jeux d'influencé qui finalement
sont sacrifiés au profit de valeurs
fondamentales qui malheureusement dans
ce contexte on ont été bafoués y compris
al venus d'ailleurs il ya un passage
avec antonio gutiérrez ou 10 pour
l'impression qu'ils portent le monde sur
ses épaules le pot oui bien sûr mais
c'est une c voilà j'ai voulu le faire
avec humour parce que comme le dit brel
je pense que l'humour est probablement
l'une des lunes des
deux meilleurs moyens pour pour raconter
un peu
7,7 cette difficulté à vivre ensemble en
fait un mot rapide en une minute de la
tunisie qui doit accueillir normalement
le sommet de la francophonie au mois de
novembre pour le cinquantenaire de
l'organisation
cette rencontre elle a déjà été reportée
l'année dernière en raison de logistique
notamment depuis quelqu'un essayait de
concentre tous les pouvoirs le président
dirige la tunisie par décret-loi ça fait
craindre des dérives autocratiques
est-ce que selon vous ce sommet de la
francophonie va pouvoir se tenir dans
ces conditions dans ces conditions ça
semble difficile si on veut rester
cohérent avec le projet global de
l'organisation effectivement on a du mal
à imaginer à la même table le président
français elle prévu une escale a dit le
premier ministre québécois et les autres
chefs d'état à la même table que le
président tunisien donc je pense qu'il
va falloir qu'il trouve compromis d'une
manière ou d'une autre on parle beaucoup
de l'hypothèse de sommets rapide
appareil pour entériner effectivement le
renouvellement du le mandat de la
secrétaire général actuel merci beaucoup
merci bertin leblanc j'appelle le titre
de ce cette bd éléments de langage
cacophonie en francophonie signé longue
bertin leblanc avec des illustrations de
paul gross aux éditions la boîte à
bulles merci bertin nous avoir rendu
visite
après presque 15 ans
ici c'est un plaisir vous retrouvez dans
nos locaux allait très bientôt merci et
merci à vous d'avoir choisi france 24 on
se retrouve dans quelques minutes pour
la suite de paris direct
[Musique]